um I'm John Reger I'm a professor at the
University of Utah and I'm going to talk
about something that I've worked on for
you know the last 15 years or so so I'm
just sort of curious how many people uh
here have reported a compiler
bug good good good good uh how many
people so this should be a super set
right have been 100% sure you've seen a
compiler bug but maybe didn't report one
yeah sure sure sure reporting one's a
pain right it's it's it's sort of you
know it's it's it takes work and um many
people probably ran into one but aren't
100%
certain yeah sometimes it's hard right
because like the compiler bugs are in
the kind of corner cases of the standard
where you don't understand the they the
compiler developers don't either right
so like you know some sometimes yeah
sometimes we're not sure um you know if
it crashes that's easy but today I'm
going to talk more about uh the kind of
bugs that are not so
easy um so so compiler bugs show
themselves in a variety of ways right uh
sometimes the compiler just exits
abnormally other times it uh quite
commonly actually emits improper debug
debug code uh for you know improper
debug symbols and things um sometimes it
errors out when it shouldn't sometimes
it shouldn't error out but it does uh
lovm sort of likes to uh hang forever
because sometimes two optimizations kind
of get in a fight and uh just undo each
other forever and so the compiler hangs
um and the kind of compiler bug that I
sort of probably will focus on the most
here is the kind where it emits code
silently you know without telling you
that doesn't do what you said to do um
that's kind of the most pricious kind
probably and you know a lot of these
anyway those are the kind that I sort of
have have dealt with the most um so let
me just tell a sort of a really quick
story about an embedded C compiler so I
was teaching an embedded software class
back when I was a fresh young new
professor you know 20 years ago and um
we spent a lot of time in the class just
looking at code we'd look at some C code
and we look at the translation and of
course this is what you do in an a beta
systems class you're so close to the you
want to sort of know what the compiler
is doing what it's thinking and a
student sort of uh said uh hey professor
uh that looks wrong you know the trans
the translation looked looked wrong and
I hadn't noticed this and a student was
right and I just assumed I had done a
cut cut and paste error while making my
slides but I checked later that evening
and um I hadn't made a cut and paste
error the compiler was wrong and um on
Tuesday night um John Hay sort of
mentioned this kind of phenomenon where
you sort of start to look into something
and each time you look into it something
gets worse and you get angrier and more
frustrated and it just it just really
started to bother me more and more um
over the sub succeeding years that this
thing which we trust to do the job just
wasn't doing the job and this this
particular Rea compiler I won't mention
its name but it was really wrong it was
almost harder to get it to generate
correct code than incorrect code um you
know of course that's not the case for
most compilers we use and I don't
unfortunately have the example anymore
of that compiler I've lot sort of the
the actual code Snippets have been lost
to time but I'll show you a different
example so here's an embedded system
sish snippet of code you know you
wouldn't write this code right this
isn't useful but um so we have volatile
INX and um we we load it and then store
it and you know according to the rules
for volatile this needs to result at the
at the um generated code level at as a
load in a store of the same value and um
MSP 430 GCC at the time I started
looking into all this uh emitted uh just
a return it just said optimize it away
uh and actually still does I just went
to compiler explore just before this
talk and the current version still does
like what the hell like how do embedded
systems work if it's just optimizing
away accesses to viables I don't know
some some of these things don't have
here here's another one where I don't
have a good answer so this is a function
so this is a silly function right this
is a silly small function designed to
expose a compiler bug but this function
has to return zero on you know Common
implementation defined platforms and um
years ago the the the vers the then
current version of wuntu Linux shipped
with a version of GCC that made it
return one at all optimization level s
and like every single package including
the kernel on this on this distribution
was compiled with this compiler like how
did it work like I don't know I've never
I've never even understood this right
like and this this this particular bug
was you know a very nasty one it wasn't
actually a GCC defect it was that the
abunto people had somehow saw fit to uh
apply about five megabytes of patches to
GCC and then and then deploy that one
and they they broke things sort of badly
so um so I don't want to give you the
impression that all the compiler bugs
are you know 20 years ago so here's one
that's just from last month um so here's
a compiler a GCC developer replying to
my student who reported the test case
with a better reduced version of the
test case and here the the Crux of it is
um a comparison or the complement of the
comparison GCC got that wrong a month
ago and it had been sitting there for
like a long time maybe you just don't do
that right that's sort of stupid code
maybe you just don't do that but that
was sitting in G in Mainline GCC for for
years just this there's sort of weird
stuff going on where there can be some
pretty significantly broken stuff
sitting there and you know we just don't
know and as a user as a developer um
because undefined behavior in these
languages is so pernicious um we often
just assume it's our fault right or or
something's going wrong you just tweak
the code you're like what the hell you
start rewriting it different ways you
often work around compiler bugs without
even noticing it it's a weird it's a
weird it's a weird world we live in um
so those were wrong code bugs and I'll
just show an example of a crash bug so
here's one from last summer so this
particular code snippet here uh made GCC
seg fault and um you know why that
particular snippet of code you know the
GCC developers knew and you know you if
you so so I'm I'm including Links at the
bottom of a lot of these slides so you
know I like to show the receipts for
these kind of things so if you do feel
like uh getting the slides later and
clicking on these you can read the whole
discussion um but anyway you know of
course they they fix this kind of thing
so
um so those are a few examples and so so
those are some bad things right I showed
you some bad things that we don't want
the compiler to do
um but what do we know about correct
compilers I mean should we just say it's
one that never does the bad things
that's not a very good definition right
I mean in practice that's what we want
but it's not a constructive definition
right it doesn't tell us what we should
be building it tells us what we
shouldn't be building um and it's not so
easy to say what what a correct compiler
is and that leads us to problems if we
decide to prove compilers correct so
compilers are like the most eminently
provable math objects in on the world
because you know they're purely
mathematical right they take a
mathematical construct a source language
they turn it into a different ma
mathematical construct a target language
and in the middle they're not concurrent
they're not depending on very much it's
just a it's just a pure function
essentially um from from what from an
input to an output we should be able to
prove these correct but to do that we
need to know what they should do and to
know what they should do we need a
semantics for the source language and
that doesn't even exist for common
languages like for example Swift or C++
creating a mechanized formal semantic
for C++ is nobody's ever even I think
made a serious try at it it's just it's
just too hard and other languages are in
the same both um rust has mechanized
formal semantics but none of them that I
that I looked at I thought were probably
complete you know I could be wrong about
that but Swift definitely doesn't have
one and a mechanized formal semantics is
just table Stakes that's that's just the
very first thing you need and
um um once you have that you can start
to try to prove a compiler correct but
but realistically um that's proving a
approved correct compiler is not
compatible with compiler compiler
development as we understand it in the
world it's too honorous it imposes too
big of a burden on compiler developers I
can't keep implementing optimizations I
can't keep implementing new language
standards it's just it's just sort of in
my view in a short and medium term uh
just a non-starter we're not going to do
this it's not what we want what we want
is compilers that don't have a lot of
bugs but this isn't the way to get there
in my
opinion so where are compilers incorrect
well you know the specification can be
hard to understand so I've run into many
cases where I found something where my
reading of for example the C standard
and the compiler developers just
differed and um you know some sometimes
they right sometimes I was right right
you know it's it's English and it's not
even really very good English often um
you know there's there's legitimate
ambiguity developers often haven't had
time to catch up with the specification
especially in C++ like you know visual
visual C++ was I think um in slightly
incompatible in its templates with the
specification for for years and years
and years and years right they just
couldn't quite get over that hurdle to
you know making templates work um
sometimes we just don't have enough test
cases there's all sorts of reasons why
compilers are wrong um and the one that
kind of most interests me sort of
professionally is developers Miss Corner
cases and the reason that that's sort of
the most interesting is these other ones
are more sort of human software process
issues often hard to attack as a as as
an academic logic errors I can attack so
let me show you a logic error this is
this is a corner case that I really
enjoyed finding this is maybe last
spring or something so lovm internally
has these intrinsic functions for
checked arithmetic operations so one of
them is signed multiply by overflow it
takes two inputs it multiplies them and
it returns a pair the pair contains the
result the two's complement result at
the same bitwidth as the inputs and so
here I should say that this um these
particular intrinsics work at any width
you can pass them any width integer and
they just they just do what they should
do so it Returns the result at at the
bitwidth and then the Overflow is a
Boolean flag indicating whether overflow
occurred so that's straightforward
enough and of course the reason we do
this is to expose you know provide sort
of a uniform access to the processor's
condition code Flags which are typically
not accessible from The Source level so
this is an inside lvm where um you know
where we where we need access efficient
access to these lower level abstractions
so the lvm middle end which is where a
lot of the optimizations happen and also
in its back ends um there's some
redundancy in optimizations they all
contained an optimization which took a
sign multiply with overflow of a and one
so any arbitrary integer and one and
returned reduced that to a pair um a and
false so if you multiply a * 1 you uh
get a back and it doesn't overflow right
does that seem fairly clear can we buy
it it's
wrong it took me a while to see this the
the theorem prover I was interacting
with uh told me found a bug related to
this and I just I thought the theor
prove was wrong for like an hour um
before I figured it out does anybody
it's a it's a nasty Corner case it's
it's a one bit multiply sign multiply
with overflow do you see the problem now
what does one
mean to's complement wise at one bit
wide it's not one right it's minus one
there's no identity element for
multiplication at one bit wide the
optimization breaks uh does anybody care
I don't know I just enjoyed finding it
because I thought it was very funny um
and of course they you know of course
they have to fix this kind of thing
because even if it's funny and even if
nobody cares it's still you know
mathematically wrong and as Engineers we
fix that stuff so anyway I show this to
illustrate how hard these Corner cases
can be to see I don't think that many
people in this room and certainly not me
would have seen this problem just kind
of of um you know while we were coding
it up right that's a pretty innocuous
looking optimization and you know it's
it's not right and so that's a you know
we see a lot of stuff like this so now
it comes time to sort of ask you a
question um you know do you want your
compiler to be correct raise your hand
if you want your compiler to be correct
yeah but that's like security right we
all want security but we don't we truly
don't want security because we want a
usable phone the secure phone is the one
that's you know buried in concrete and
dropped into the ocean right that's a
secure phone we want to use it we we
want insecure phones we don't want
correct compilers we want sort of
correct compilers so if you had to
rewrite all of your code if I gave you a
correct compiler in a language that's
different than your codebase I don't
think you'd care right if I gave you a
correct compiler for the which the
license cost as much as your salary I
don't think you'd switch to it you
wouldn't switch to it if it didn't
optimize you wouldn't switch to it if it
didn't support templates or something
right we want correctness but we don't
want it that badly there's an Optimum
point for correctness and it's not all
the way at the correct side right you
know just it's just sort of a a reality
a reality of sort of engineering and
economic life and so so engineering
there's a lot of definitions for
engineering but one that I like is you
know it's accomplishing goals with
limited resources if resources are
unlimited it's not engineering it's you
know imagination or playing or something
right this this this is a this this
isn't something that's interesting or
exists so given that compiler Engineers
only have they're expensive people
there's not that many of them and every
day they have to do something right they
have to wake up go to their computer and
do something what are they going to do
are they going to fix bugs in
correctness reported by users are they
going to try to find new correctness
bugs are they going to re-engineer parts
of the compiler that have been
incredibly Troublesome and prone to bugs
so they are less prone to bugs what are
they going to do well it turns out
they're probably not going to do any of
this right they're not going to do any
of this what are they going to do
they're going to do what they're paid to
do right everybody makes a salary
they're going to probably make the
optimizer better they're going to
probably support c23 they're probably
going to Target the new random variant
of risk 5 that came out this month
before a new VAR comes out right that's
what they're going to do they're going
to do their day job people also fix bugs
but again the optimum point for the for
correctness and Bug fixing isn't at um
you know completely correct that's not
really achievable um in any in any sort
of time frame and there's a really nice
paper that I found um a while ago and
not that many people know it and I I
really really love this paper it's
called the impact of Economics on
compiler optimization so here the guy
Robinson the author looked did all
47,000 papers on economics you know
electronically obviously and all 12,000
papers on compiler optimization and he
found one that had a meaningful
discussion of the impact of Economics on
compiler optimization so then he goes
and writes a short paper on this and
it's totally worth reading it's it's
really sort of nice short paper um
nobody so far as far has written um the
impact of Economics on compiler
correctness so oh well I'll just be
waiting um so as I've been saying
there's a bit of a global Optimum here
where if we look at compiler quality as
a as a function of you know we could
spend all of our development effort
fixing bugs in which case we' never add
features that compiler sucks right
nobody wants it we can also spend all of
our effort on new features and never fix
a bug nobody wants that one either it's
just going to crash every single time
you use it there's an Optimum point in
the middle but here's the deal this
optimal point is a function of these
underlying Technologies right um we can
shift these curves by shifting how the
underlying Technologies work and that's
been sort of my goal since about 2010
trying to do research projects that
shift the economics you know maybe just
a little bit right but that shift the
economics so that maybe we could reach
an optimal Point that's a little bit
better than the natural one which we
sort of naturally get if people just do
what they
want so what does that mean in practice
that means stuff like well maybe we
could make it a lot easier to find
compiler bugs maybe we could make it a
lot easier to isolate um the root cause
of a compiler bug maybe we can um help
users de compiler users disambiguate
when the problem is not the compil
comper people used to blame the compiler
a lot for undefined behavior problems
the um GMP does anybody use the G multi
Precision Library GMP it's a big Nom
Library it had something right on the
web page that said you know GCC
frequently mcomp our library but when I
went looking for undefined behaviors in
the in the GMP Library had a lot of them
all right I think they were probably
wrong I mean maybe not 100% wrong but
they were they were wrong a lot of the
time they just had bugs that they didn't
understand as in recent years as our
understanding of undefined Behavior has
gotten better and better we've seen a
lot less blame in the compiler when the
compiler isn't wrong because as I've
been showing you the compiler is wrong
often enough we don't need to blame it
when it isn't
wrong so um what else can we do we can
prove that the compiler did the right
thing that um and then we could generate
parts of the compiler automatically and
I mentioned these specific list of
things because these are all things that
I've done you know all research projects
that I've done and I'm going to tell you
about I don't have time to tell you
about all of them but I can tell you
about a couple of them so first I'm
going to tell you about how my research
Group found and reported more than a
thousand compiler books
um
so when I started trying to think about
so I already sort of set the stage for
you a little bit where I I show told you
that I had sort of eventually noticed
that compiler bugs were a lot more
common than I had thought and I started
to find them more and more and more but
finding them by hand is incredibly
dissatisfying right I you you can only
do so in so much of this and then I
remembered that years and years ago um I
had seen this really cool paper and it
stuck in my mind uh very forcefully
because it you know because Jim Gray had
um mentioned it to me and he had been
extremely excited about this paper and
he was a very contagious sort of excite
excitement kind of man and I got excited
about it and this was massive stochastic
testing of SQL which basically just
means fuzzing a database right making
random SQL queries submitting them to
multiple databases and they were finding
things like SQL Server Like
exponentiated wrong or something like it
couldn't compute it couldn't compute an
exponent like what the hell um so this
is a really cool paper that kind of
popped into my head and then there was
another one from from sort of happened
to be from the same year differential
testing for software by McKean and this
one was a c compiler buzzer that McKean
had written back in 1998 or prior to
1998 this is a really cool paper it just
really stuck in my mind is you know he
had just had these amazing findings um
so I kind of this these techniques had
been sitting there so we went and
basically adopted them so we wrote a
program called cith my that my group
wrote and it generates random C code and
I wasn't the main off of C Smith my one
of my students was but I was um the main
one who reported the bugs and over the
years I reported you know with my you
know just by myself 500 500 and some um
and you know you you sort of learn a lot
while you're doing this and um one of my
very favorite moments of my professional
life was when um C Smith got a Christmas
card from a industrial compiler
development team they had all signed it
and they just had really enjoyed using
cith it had just found a ton of I mean
they didn't send tell me how many right
but this is an open Source tool they had
clearly had found it worthwhile enough
to actually send me a Christmas card
addressed to C Smith I was just I was
super happy it made me made me very
happy for this to happen but anyway C
Smith is old news we're not working on
it anymore I don't really want to talk
about it um what I'd like to talk about
is um its successor which my I have a
soon to graduate student who wrote A
cith successor I'll tell you a little
bit about that it's a it's a you know
it's like it's like C Smith but it's
better and what I want to start talking
about is the the key to making one of
the these tools work well is it needs to
be expressive and it needs to have
certain properties that let you find
wrong code bugs so expressiveness just
means generating a lot of different
kinds of code and having a single
interpretation means that if you run the
program it has to do a certain thing and
of course that's important because a
program that has undefined behaviors
doesn't have to do a certain thing it
can do like anything so you so if so if
you run the program generated by the
compiler and it does something random
you can make no inferences right on the
other hand if you run a program with
single interpretation
and it does something random like
crashes now now you can make a strong
inference that the compiler has a bug so
we need both of these properties and
let's talk about that a little more so
if we only care about expressiveness
generating random code is easy you just
generate any kind of crap you want and
if a pointer referencing a pointer goes
into off into space somewhere just do it
all right this doesn't give us what we
want it's easy it's it's not useful
similarly if we only care about the
single interpretation thing we can
generate a lot of random codes so maybe
I restrict myself to programs that look
like the one below right that's not
going to find compiler bugs even though
I can generate an infinite number of
programs that have that form that have
that general syntactic form right so we
need to do both of these things and
doing them both is really hard and took
us a long time this this you know each
of these C compiler fuzzers um cost one
of my students you know four or five
years of their lives right this you know
this is a fairly significant engineering
effort you know on the other hand five
person years isn't very big industrially
but academically it's big you know it's
sort of at the limit of what I can do in
in Academia you know give me a 50%
industrial team and you know I can do
different things but you know at a
university this is about the most I can
do so let's talk about the single
interpretation constraint so a CN C++
program that we generate needs to be
free of undefined behaviors and not rely
on unspecified behaviors and in some
Ideal World maybe it wouldn't rely on
implementation defined behaviors either
but in practice we' we just don't bother
no C program really fails to rely on
implementation defined behaviors and we
don't so we don't bother with this
either but we do have to avoid the first
two things and so what I want to show
you is a technique that we used in this
in this second compiler fuzer yarp gen
that was that was different than what we
did in cith for avoiding undefined
Behavior so we're generating arithmetic
Expressions that are going to be part of
a random program and here's a tiny
fragment of an arithmetic expression
that's going to be in a random program
we generate an ad operator and then
we're going to add in Max and 42 so or
we're going to add a and b which at that
program Point happen have the values at
Max and 42 so that's bad right we don't
want that to happen that's undefined the
program could explode the computer could
melt you know whatever we don't want to
do it so what we do is we just do
something really simple we have a little
canned rewrite that we use that um
transforms the addition to a subtraction
and now it becomes
defined that was easy um we can stack
this sort of concept and we apply these
kind of rewrites bottom up to a randomly
generated expression and when we get to
the root we have a a full expression
that's that's defined and this all
assumes that we know the values flowing
into it and we I'm not going to talk
about how we insure that we Ure we
ensure that we know the values flowing
into it but crucially the compiler can't
know the values flowing into it if this
makes sense the compiler has to be
solving a general problem we only reason
about a specific problem and this gives
us an incredibly sort of one-sided
weapon against the compiler that lets us
really break compilers fairly easily so
we can generate these arithmetic
expression trees and here I'll show you
sort of the Full Table of little rewrite
rules that let us generate arithmetic
Expressions avoiding undefined Behavior
it's just a lot of little little tweaks
to things but again if you take a big
random expression and apply these bottom
up you get something that that actually
works and then you put a bunch of those
together into a into a function and put
a bunch of those functions into a
program and now you have a program that
has the desired
property that's only for arithmetic
Expressions there's a completely
separate set of rules and rewrites and
things that work for pointers and arrays
and things and I'm not going to I'm just
not going to bother talking about that
um so
uh so that sort of
uh you know solve that problem but
you've noticed that we've relied on know
on knowing the values flowing through
our program and that makes extending
this scheme to Loop programs hard
because we don't want to analyze all
Loop iterations so what we do is we sort
of do some tricks we have some some
various tricks where the actual Loop
behavior is fairly restricted like for
example it might only execute once but
the compiler doesn't know this so it's
solving a general case it might execute
with the same values flowing through it
on every Loop iteration so that's two
different schemes now and again we hide
these things from the compiler we hide
these things so the compiler has to
solve a general problem we are solving a
specific problem and that's why we with
a fairly lightweight engineering can
generate pretty tough things to
compile so anyway we hide all of these
tricks from the compiler and um this
allows us to do some pretty good
compiler fuzzing and the reason we
started targeting Loops is because um
compiler Loop optimiz have gotten pretty
sophisticated in recent years driven by
you know Big Data machine learning AI
all these things have made you know lots
of Loops right compile Loop optimizers
like you know poly for example there's
never been a orginal poly that we
couldn't just break in like 10 seconds I
mean
um we want to break these Loop
optimizations has anybody looked at the
scaler Revolution module in
lovm it sort of tries to predict Which
Way a loop is going and what it's doing
and how big the steps are it is the most
heinous mess I've ever seen in my life
I've never had any sense that I had any
clue CL what was what it was really
doing um we want to fuzz the hell out of
that kind of thing because if I can't
figure it out probably the other people
can't either right they're not that much
smarter than
mecks do the tricks that's okay so s
Andre's question is do the tricks we
play reduce the bugs we can
find sometimes and we don't know are the
answers
yeah these questions are very hard to to
answer but but probably sometimes for
sure other times um we suspect maybe
it's just hard to know but the tricks
are all we have so and and they get us
pretty far so but that's a very good
question yeah um but so so what I want
to talk about now is so so I've talked
about generating code that has the
desired properties that you need to fuzz
a compiler and find wrong code bugs and
so I'll tell you now about making
expressive loops and this is um
particularly interesting and fun because
compiler Loop optimizers look for
extremely specific idioms extremely
specific Loop idioms and I'll show you
one so compilers like to do Loop Fusion
you can only do Loop Fusion when the two
Loops are next to each other they have
the same iteration space and they lack
certain kinds of dependencies that would
break um break break Loop Fusion you
know dependencies that would make you
know running the two Loops in the same
Loop um return a different result so the
compiler does some conservative checks
and it turns out that um if you generate
purely random loopy loopy code you
almost never and we checked this right
basically never trigger Loop Fusion so
we basically plug we have a sort of a
higher level intermediate representation
for the partially generated random
program that includes special commands
for generating fusible Loops okay so
that's one thing we did another thing we
did is we want to trigger stencil
optimizations so stencil codes are ones
that look at a sort of a window here I'm
showing an example that looks at a
one-dimensional window of code three
pixels in a row but it could be um you
know more commonly it'd be a it be it'
be a square aare of pixels in an image
that we're doing some sort of a stencil
computation of so a stencil computation
looks at this window a small window of
of of an array and computes a new value
out of it to to store into a into a
destination array so LM and GCC are
extremely clever with stencil codes
because they're common and their
performance critical so here you can see
on the right some arm object code where
at the left we've loaded three array
values does that kind of make sense
we've loaded three different array
values per Loop iteration but the object
code at the right loads one Loop Val one
array value per Loop iteration that's
really sort of magical and so what it
does is it loads the the the farthest
one up the i+1 and it forwards that to
subsequent Loop iterations using
registers so if you look at the code
carefully I won't try to explain it but
it but it and it'll even do this for six
for six values or seven until eventually
it runs out of registers and and stops
doing this but it's very clever and you
can reduce the memory traffic by quite a
lot for these extremely performance
critical codes so we need to trigger
that kind of optimization because that's
the kind of thing where the compiler
writers are being incredibly clever
that's where they're going to go wrong
we need to trigger it we can't find bugs
in it if we can't trigger the
optimizations so again we need some can
support for
stencils okay so I've showed you two
kinds of caned support for Loop is
idioms and we ended up with 10 of those
sort of very general purpose you know
kinds of code structures that Loop
optimizers look for and the real trick
here is that these are sort of
parameterized structure they're they're
their structure that's parameterized by
Randomness and they compose with each
other so for for example we can have a a
reduction of Dimension and compose that
with a stencil computation and you get
something like what we show what we show
on the slide here and you know these
combined with fusable loops these things
composed fairly nicely we get pretty
dense collections of pretty interesting
Loop idioms that look sort of like what
people would have written while
retaining enough Randomness to really uh
make the compiler have to work hard to
do a correct
job so that's what Yar genen did that so
the the first generation of yarp genen
sort of didn't focus on Loops didn't
didn't do very interesting stuff with
loops the second version of it uh my
student focused heavily on loops and you
this is really fun and so in total
across the two versions We got 183 wrong
code bugs mostly in GCC and lvm but also
in some other compilers 157 crash bugs
and then the nice thing is most of these
hav been fixed so if the compiler
developers weren't fixing the bugs we
submitted this would be the most useless
effort on a planet does that kind of
make sense this this benefits nobody if
we just add issues that the people don't
want to fix but the thing is compiler
developers You know despite the fact
that as I said earlier they had
something else to do that day you know
they always have something else to do
that day um despite that fact um they do
fix these bugs and a lot of it is
because open source developers aren't as
uh beholden to corporations as uh you
know as as other people are they they
often have I I'm not sure about this but
it seems like the open source world with
public issue trackers people are more
likely to fix bugs the the bugs that
when I when we first started doing cith
I started submitting bugs to Arms
compiler team to um
Sons which existed at the time um none
of them cared they they they they they
reacted somewhere between um disdain and
hostility because I wasn't a customer
right I wasn't paying their job was to
work for the customer they didn't have
for whatever reason a lot of
Professional Pride in their project they
they just wanted to work on the bottom
line the open source developers sticks
them and it's really good so that's how
we can sort of move forward and what
happened what really happened I think is
these compilers kind of um their
complexity exceeded what people could
really understand they got really big
and Bloated really smart and there were
just a lot of latent bugs so when cith
laid into these compilers it was just it
was just like farming right it was just
like farming bugs I mean it took a while
to you know it took a while to even
generate programs that they wouldn't
misc compile it was weird um you know
then eventually over the years the
compilers become resistant to our tools
and eventually you know currently if you
use yarp gen on the current on the
latest trunk version of GCR LM it might
take a couple of days to find a bug and
so that's that's what we want right
that's what we want is re reach a state
where we've sort of saturated the
ability of our tool to find bugs and
then we can sort of keep running it and
now we're finding new bugs instead of
old bugs and new bugs are awesome old
bugs suck because the person's probably
not working at the company anymore and
if they are they're doing something
different the bug that just got
committed yesterday the code is fresh in
somebody's mind if I can report that
within a couple of days of it getting
committed to the code base um they
remember what they're doing they're
still working on it they probably have
time they're going to fix it and so
that's so it took a took a long time but
we eventually with these compilers got
more or less to where we wanted to
be
okay so um yarp Jen's primary author
actually essentially only author is uh
my PhD student seid and uh y he he put a
lot of effort into writing a good driver
for it like it'll run C ruce when it
finds something it'll it'll it'll you
know it'll it'll minimize the the bug
that it found um it's it'll use all the
cores on your machine it's really easy
to use yarp gen it's open source so if
if you feel like trying to break a
compiler uh you know it's it's it's it's
it's out there waiting for you but if
you do use it we'd love to know um
because a lot of people use it and never
tell us and um you know one thing we did
is we got the GCC people to to keep a
meta bug for yarp Gen where if they if a
bug is found using YP gen they add it to
a list um tracking the bugs found with
the YP gen and this is really cool
because it helps us keep score there
used to be a compiler fuzzer for
JavaScript called JS fun fuzz and
Mozilla eventually closed access to that
um to that page to the metab buug for it
but it had well over a thousand bugs it
was just this massive wall spider monkey
was just a unbelievable pile of bugs
when JS fun funf sort of laid into it
and just just completely just found so
many it was it was unbelievable just
looking at looking at what this the
author of JS funfa accomplished and of
course JavaScript is security critical
so that really mattered
there okay so I'm going to switch gears
a little bit
now
so let's talk about something that one
of my it's a little bit more current
work so like I say uh Yar genen is um my
my students graduating soon um he's kind
of wrapping up his his his main
development on it unless he happens to
get hired by a company who uh who uh
wants to pay him to work on it you know
that'd be nice but I'm not sure if
that'll happen so let's talk about
generating parts of a compiler
automatically and so why would you want
to generate parts of a compiler
automatically it's because they're buggy
when you write them by hand that's why I
want to do it I mean there's lots of
other reasons but from the compiler bug
point of view if we can generate
something systematically and
automatically you know we should do it
so let's talk about generating a
Optimizer so optimizers are super fun
artifacts um and something that's really
interesting about people optimizers is
that um almost every compiler has one
it's it's usually the first Optimizer
that a compiler gets so even really
really dumb basic compilers like written
in Python for some little DSL they get a
people Optimizer pretty quickly because
they can clean up a lot of local
inefficiencies in code and they're
simple and you can sort of incrementally
improve them so what does a people
optimization look like well the one I've
shown in the middle of the slide here is
is is using a demorgan law to do some
arithmetic simplification so the
complement of a anded with the
complement of B can be turned into the
complement of a orb saving one operation
right it's three operations on the leth
hand side two operations on the right
hand side that's more efficient and so
what a people Optimizer is is it's a
collection of about 10,000 of these in
the case of lvm it's a absolutely
gigantic number of these
and it turned out to be a truly big
mindfield of corner case errors because
every single one of these you know I'm
I'm making up 10,000 at some number but
they're mixed together so it's really
hard to count them so I don't know how
many there are but every single one of
them is a separate opportunity to be
wrong and many of them involve very
finicky reasoning you know de Morgan
here is not we're not going to get this
wrong right but a lot of other ones are
very tricky and it turned out that when
we started fuzzing lovm using cith the
people Optimizer was actually the single
buggiest component of it so I considered
it really ripe for ripe for replacement
um that's that's been on been on my list
for a long time and we finally in a
couple in the last recent years got
around to doing this project so let's
talk about how this works so um the
first thing we
did was um something that turned out to
not be necessarily the right solution
but I'm going to describe it kind of
quickly anyway we created a tool called
a super Optimizer a super Optimizer is
an Optimizer that uses meaningful search
so most compiler optimizations have no
search component right they just decide
whether to do something and they either
I mean they they just either do
something or don't do something does
that kind of make sense they're not
trying things and backing out and
looking at the results and evaluating
they don't do that they don't have time
everybody everybody hates a slow
compiler and search is not something we
have time for in a compiler because it's
getting this mountain of like 35
megabytes of C++ once you've expanded
the includes and it I mean there's no
surge it's it's hard to even just get
through it at
all okay so what the super Optimizer
does is slices out part of an lvm
function so this is inside the compiler
so we have the elev we're operating at
the level of lm's intermediate
representation here it slices out part
of the function and it uses a technique
called program synthesis to try to
compute it the whatever whatever that
whatever that slice computed it tries to
do it more efficiently and it uses
program synthesis to do that program
synthesis is sort of a slightly magical
solver based technique for creating code
that conforms to a specification so here
the specification is the original sliced
code and we're just syn trying to
synthesize something and either
synthesis succeeds in which case um we
we we computed the value more
efficiently or it fails in which case
you know we we just move on and we you
know we we don't have a people
optimization there and in the super tool
after it computes a people optimization
you know can optionally apply it you
know actually do the optimization and
optionally cach it for the future
because synthesis is really slow so this
works and so we're done no we're not
done we're not done at all this this
we're not we're not even like a little
bit done so super is incredibly slow
because it relies on making a massive
number of calls to a theum Z3 um in
order to do synthesis so synthesis is
this thing you know it's it's it's it's
based on a formal specification for LM
intermediate representation and you know
to evaluate the meaning of a piece of
lovm intermediate representation you
know we we are asking Z3 lots of
questions and to do synthesis we have to
ask it a huge number of questions so the
search Space is really very large super
is incredibly so nobody wants to load an
optimization pass that makes their
compiler 150 times slower and 150 times
is just a magic number you can make
super as fast or as slow as you want by
tuning it synthesis if you make it
really fast it doesn't do anything and
if you make it take three weeks it'll do
something but like nobody felt like
waiting three weeks for their program to
compile okay so
um nobody wants a slow compiler right so
um so the question is what do we do next
so this is a way to get people
optimizations for free at some level we
can automatically construct most of what
we find in lm's people optimizers or
maybe not most of much of it um but it's
impractical so what are we going to do
so this is what my current student is
working on so let's talk about how super
has impacted lvm it's impacted lvm
indirectly with a human in the loop so
what people do occasionally is they'll
run super on some LM intermediate
representation it'll spit out some
optimizations then they go ahead and
look at those really carefully and
Implement them as part of the people
Optimizer which is called inst combin
and lvm so that's how super has had
impact on lvm and there's a bunch of
lovm optimizations that came from super
right it's had it's had a good amount of
impact but this isn't how we wanted to
do it we don't want the person doing
this because um it turns out that the
the this process of manually taking
something generated by super which is a
completely specific optimization and
generalizing it to make it something
that you know can be used in in in a
more General case inside the compiler
that's the hard part that's the error
prone part that's where people make
mistakes and we turned out we automated
the wrong thing basically so spotting
the M optimization is what Super's great
at that's not really the hardest part
the hard part is is is the next part so
now we have now we next Tred to attack
the hard part let's talk talk about the
hard part so let's say super C's um x *
2 it would synthesize x shift left by
one on many platforms that's considered
desirable right um the multiplier is a
more expensive piece of Hardware than a
shifter so that's a good
optimization that is um not General
that's specific the thing the compiler
developer would Implement is the
generalized version of it and how do we
generalize this well let's go through
what our generalization tool chain does
and also this is basically mirrors what
a compiler developer would do by hand
but again they screw it up this
generalization part is hard um it's
really not easy okay so we have x x 2
being Rewritten as X left shifted by one
what do we need to do what's the what's
the what's the obvious thing to
generalize first here who wants to just
yell
out yeah two is a very weird choice of
number we don't want to just optimize
multiplying by two right that's stupid
okay so what do we want to do well we
want to multiply x times a constant and
then we're going to
that's going to turn into shifting left
by some other constant now there's two
problems with this one is that we can't
do that for all choices of C right this
only works for specific choices of C
somebody just yell it
out powers of two of course the other
thing is we haven't we don't know how to
compute D yet okay so we've broken the
optimization completely so what do we do
well we're going to compute a
precondition in order to make this re
optimization only fire when it's able to
work and so we do it like this we add a
precondition called you know using a
lovm built-in primitive is Power of Two
And if it is a power of two then we can
fire the optimization and how do we get
the precondition well we use program
synthesis again this has been a really
fun part of this project is we had this
program synthesis engine that we wrote
for super we just keep calling it again
and again um in different parts of this
tool and I'm not even going to tell you
about all of them I'm just going to tell
you about a few of them okay so this
works but we still haven't figured out
how to compute D and so now I've already
told you how to compute D what do we
do how do we figure out how to compute
D no that's how you compute it but how
do how how do how does my generalization
tool do it program synthesis right
program synthesis so we synthesize a log
function of C and you know now we get a
complete optimization this actually
works so this is a correct optimization
it's significantly more General it
hasn't been generalized completely yet
and so in one tiny way in which we can
make it more General is we'd also like
to apply this to the commuted version
that's pretty trivial um there's a very
big missing part here which is we want
to make the thing work at different bit
widths and this is this turned out to be
a pretty tricky problem so in LM
intermediate inside the compiler things
can be arbitrary bitwidth right they're
fixed withth but they're arbitrary and
when you build the Levan compiler using
itself you see integers of every bit
width from one to like 87 and then from
87 it's sparsely populated up to
320 why do you see a 320 bit integer I
don't even remember I I looked into this
one time why do we see every single
integer withth up to 87 just it just
does that that's how it works so
optimizations need to work on um values
of arbitrary bitwidth okay so I'm going
to talk about that on the next slide so
I'm not going to talk about it too much
here because it's hard um and I want to
add that every step of the every at
every step of the generalization
pipeline here we're proving the thing
correct so we we make sure to never
break it or I mean we do break it sort
of temporarily at step two right but we
we sure we make sure we to move it back
to a correct optimization using a tool
called alive 2 which is something that
my research group works on although
we're not the primary developers of it
um it is a mechanized semantics for the
lovm intermediate representation that
can basically tell you whether rewriting
X toy is is legal according to the rules
of lvm
optimizations
uh yeah I'm possibly simplifying here I
think this one pro I think this one
works both both ways I think this one
works both ways but division certainly
wouldn't right unsigned and signed
division are totally different I'm I'm
pretty sure this one is okay for for
just for just for a bit Vector X right
it doesn't we don't care if it signed or
unsigned I'm pretty sure this works for
multip for the multiplication rules but
I'd have to go check and so live to is
this tool we created and so one thing
that I did that I'm pretty happy with is
I so it's you can hardly see it at the
bottom there but I made a compiler
Explorer instance that gives you access
to a live 2 so you can um paste
something like this so the question
Andre asked is does this work for for
you know in general you could you could
you could ask lvm this question I mean
you could ask a live to this question in
a compiler Explorer instance and it
would just do it it would just tell you
that it works I hope um anyway so I
didn't paste this exact I didn't paste
this exact stuff into into Al Live
2 anyway so by creating this thing which
confine compiler bugs um you know we
also enabl the syn synthesis engine and
this generalization engine to work so
this has been really cool okay so now I
want to talk about the hard part here
which is the bitwidth independence this
turned out to be really difficult
because so you remember on the previous
slide we had to compute that constant D
at any bitwidth so we have to compute we
have to synthesize code which computes a
specific constant that's in a bitwidth
independent fashion does that kind of
make sense so it has to work at all
bitwidth humans do that naturally pretty
well it turned out to be really hard to
get our synthesis engine to respect that
constraint um and this is made more
Tricky by the fact that some
optimizations aren't bit with
independent and I already showed you an
example that example optimizing the sign
multiply with overflow worked at all bit
withth other than one there's plenty of
optimizations that you know have weird
weird quirky Corner cases at different
bit widths and we have to respect those
in this in this pipeline or else we'll
get it wrong and then finally there's
lots of optimizations and I'm not going
to show you any today but there's lots
of obervations that involve values of
different wids we're truncating we're
extending we're doing all sorts of crazy
stuff and working with those in a bit
with independent fashion is actually
quite difficult because you know the
shape of the thing you're dealing with
it's only sort of loosely constrained
right they're not it's it's not like the
whole thing's at the same bit with
there's all sorts of variables going on
and you know this this is fairly hard
stuff so um furthermore Z3 our
underlying theor improver gives us
essentially no help it's it Z3 can only
answer questions about us specific bit
with and the general questions we want
to ask it we can't ask it we have to
solve them separately ourselves and a
little bit of work on this in other
theor improvers that aren't Z3 but uh
it's it's not production ready so we had
to do this all ourselves so we didn't
understand how hard this would be or
that this was really a real problem and
when when my student and I finally
figured out this is a problem it set us
back a year or so but while we figured
it all out but on the plus side you know
we've sort of got a handle on this now
and it's it's it's really cool stuff
it's really cool work that I'm that I'm
super excited
about okay so let's say that all works
and it mostly does right I'm telling you
about a re about a research project
that's in a fair really good State at
this point so let's tell see what we do
with it so we take the generalized
optimization we turn it into C++ so C++
is lm's implementation language so if we
want to actually run our generalized
optimizations we have to turn them into
C++ so we do it and we get something you
know a little more complicated than what
I'm showing you here but it's basically
the same thing so let's just talk
through this quickly so um there's a
sort of a domain specific pattern
matcher in lovm that this match
construct gets us into and so we're
saying is for an instruction I um we
want to match it if it's a
multiplication of some value that's
going to be stored into X and some
constant that's going to be stored into
C so now if that matches we're going to
get an X and specific X and C to work
with so that's nice um if it doesn't
match then we we don't get these values
of course and we just fall out uh the MC
m means we're matching a communative
mole it'll multiply it'll match X time C
or c x x just sort of nice little
freebie there um so if the match matches
so if the structural prerequisite for
the for the optimization is holds and
also
the constant is a power of two then we
can replace all uses of I with um a
fresh shift that we've created a fresh
fresh left shift by the proper amount so
we generate this entirely automatically
um this is not far from what a person
would write there's other cases where we
where we generate really weird stuff
because you know this this synthesis
engine is not constrained by how you
think or how I think it just creates
random stuff some of this stuff is
really hard to understand other times
like this it generates what what we had
sort of expected to see and now we have
a optimization code that we can load
into an LM pass and just drop it into
lvm as a shared library and go so we can
turn off instamine and we can turn on
our thing and we can just go and it
works um and it's very cool it's not as
good because we you know we still have
some things missing inamine can play a
lot of tricks that we can't play yet um
like for example it has an alias
analysis built in and we don't but you
know we're doing pretty well so let me
show you one more example here
um when we look in the LM issue tracker
they they they track a lot of issues
where there's a missing people op to a
that they want that they nobody's had
time to implement yet so here's one so
Nikita here has said um on June 23rd
said well here so the the the the the
thing at the top the top block of code
that's what Nikita noticed in some code
that could be Rewritten as the code
below and Nikita has very uh uh
conveniently included a link to our
compiler Explorer instance to
demonstrate that Nikita has found an
optimization is actually correct you
know so he just shells out to a compiler
Explorer which um you know proves it
correct right right right right on the
Fly for you right there um so this is
correct nobody's had time to implement
it yet and the thing is we can hand this
particular thing to our generalization
engine and it just it just works it so
we looked at you know maybe the last 10
of these the most recent 10 of these in
the LM issue tracker it doesn't work for
all of them it works for like eight of
them um and so you know this is I think
it stands to be something that might be
able to change you know again the
premise here is we wanted to change the
the the the the the economics of
compiler development if we can take a
chunk of the compiler that people had a
hard time getting right and just take it
away from them just give them correct
code maybe this changes the economics in
a favorable fashion I don't know maybe
it frees up that engineer to fix a bug
now instead of um working on a people
Optimizer maybe it you know maybe maybe
it has some other good effect I don't
know we'll
see okay so I'm finishing up here so
generalizing optimization so this is the
PHD work for my student manage um we
don't have a public version of this yet
but I really would like to put up a
compiler Explorer instance that not only
has a live 2 in it like we've already
done but also has this generalization
engine in it so people can take stuff
like Nikita's um little little issue
paste it in and it just gives you the C
plus code that would be suitable for
pasting into the compiler I really want
to do that but you know the thing is
slow it crashes you know it's it's
research software you know um anyway so
in the future I think that other parts
of compilers are very amenable to this
approach compilers again they're
inherently mathematical objects they're
solving well understood mathematical
problems with well understood properties
everything they do is mechanized and yet
they're these monster collections of C++
it's it's almost a travesty to see it's
it's just it's just it's just kind of
wrong um how we build them and so you
know I think we can do better and so you
know hopefully we can automatically
construct lots of other parts
too I'm done and thank you very
[Applause]
much do we take a few minutes for
questions or should we just everybody
get get to the train
station okay okay
sure the I didn't talk about but that
makes a very small test case typically
for a bug trigger and now you just look
at it look at all the you know you
now you have to look at all the other
bugs and and try not to report
it we've duplicated before we we we
these are these are ones that the
compiler developers have confirmed as as
as as as real yeah thank you yeah
Jason yes so the question is Jason asked
is yeah have we learned novel
optimizations so far it hasn't the
synthesis engine is not smart enough
that it's reached what I would consider
the point of sort of creativity it's not
at the algorithm level um it's not
synthesizing like a you know so has
everybody looked at a fast pop count
fast pop counts are awesome I totally
encourage you if you haven't gone to
look at the Wikipedia page for pop count
go look at the Wikipedia page for popc
count or Hamming haming weight um you
know it's a number of set bits in a word
the the fastest algorithms for this are
awesome um you know this technique and
principle could could make a could make
a faster one than anybody's ever seen if
if it exists um in practi
this that's beyond the scope of our
synthesis engine which can only makes a
couple of instructions at a time the
search space is exponential it's not to
the point where where it's making
algorithms it's still doing fairly basic
things I haven't seen any new
discoveries yet although it does come up
with a lot of stuff that I don't
understand
yeah there's a lot of them that I just
don't understand and you say ah you know
I mean I believe the theorem Pro but I
have no idea what the hell's going
on
Victor
is there any way toate the process
ofing
yeah okay so Victor asked some about
optimization phase ordering this is a
hard problem we don't have really very
good work very good solutions to that
yet there's actually a whole bunch of
subtleties like that that I didn't
mention here that we're sort of working
on we don't necessarily have great ideas
uh all what I'll just say is these
mechanically discovered optimizations
are really amenable to reordering and
doing whatever you want with because
they're nice separable pieces whereas
the human written stuff is just a big
jumbled mess um so the potential is
there but I'm not sure we have the ideas
yet okay we'll one
more the question is yeah for other
languages yeah so so for example I
mentioned a little bit that JS fun fuzz
is a is a fuzzer that found a huge
number of vulnerabilities in spider
monkey um most many languages now have a
fuzzer when I started doing this people
were I got a lot of hostility actually
it was very fun because I I thrive on I
thrive on hostility uh but but but
people people have come around I don't
think anybody can I don't think I think
you have to build a fuzzer if you build
a new compiler build a new language I
think you just have to do it if you if
you want it to be very good eventually I
mean not at first right but after a
couple of years you
do can my tool be adapted to other
languages no no very specific that
that's a that's another dream the the
generic fuzzer is is a different dream
but that that that would be great but
but no okay than thank you very much
everyone